accusations and counter-accusations
mount regarding brett Cavanaugh's
nomination Ted Cruz is run out of a
restaurant and president Trump visits
the UN ie Mos Eisley I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
hey well I'm back and I am very excited
to be here I mean I was out for two days
and apparently the world exploded and
then I returned this morning and things
were just as bad I mean Michael avenatti
is making all sorts of trouble lots of
parties happening all over the place
Plus Ted Cruz gets run out of restaurant
we do have a lot to get to hear today
I'm gonna get to all of it in just a
second but first let me tell you about
Portugal so here is the situation right
now right now our national debt which is
money we've other countries and unfunded
liabilities that we owe to ourselves
it's greater than the entire economic
output of the United States if your
entire life savings is tied to the US
dollar ask yourself what is your plan
for hyperinflation
if the stilts should fall out from under
the economy well this is one of the
reasons why you should be at least a
little diversified you should have some
of your money in precious metals because
precious metals do in fact hedge against
inflation the hedge against uncertainty
they hedge against instability gold is a
safe haven against all that stuff my
savings plan is diversified and yours
should be to go check out Birch gold
group right now they have thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews and a plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau what's your plan
well part of it should be Birch gold
group you all know about Birch Gold's
free information kit but for a limited
time qualified purchases can earn up to
an additional 10,000 dollars in precious
metals for free through September 30th
to find out if your purchase will
qualify contact Birch gold right now go
to birchgold.com slash Bend speak to a
Birch gold rep mention I sent you that's
birchgold.com slash been do it now the
offer only runs through September 30th
terms and limitations do with fly actors
ask our sales representative for details
all right so a lot breaking this morning
Michael avenatti has now come forward
with his bombshell accusation and this
is one of these accusations where it's
either true or its false and if it's
true it shouldn't be all that hard to
prove because the witness who avenatti
is bringing forward is claiming an
enormous number of people who should
have seen this going on who should have
seen the events going on so here's
what's happening the precursor was that
michael avenatti over the past 48 hours
while I was out announced that he had a
woman who was willing to come forward
and testify that Brett Kavanaugh was
involved in a game a gang rape ring okay
that was legitimately his words so
avenatti wrote Sunday in an email to
Mike Davis quote
the chief council for nominations for
the Senate Judiciary Committee we are
aware of significant evidence of
multiple house parties in the Washington
DC area during the early 1980s during
which Brett Kavanaugh mark judge and
others would participate in the
targeting of women with alcohol / drugs
to allow a train of men who subsequently
gang-raped them he says there are
multiple witnesses that will corroborate
these facts each of them must be called
to testify publicly now it is worth
noting that Michael avenatti has in the
past come up with some credible
accusations ie stormy Daniels and in the
past he's made some non credible
accusations so for example he claimed
that he had a DVD of Trump engaged in
sexual congress and he suggested there
were three other women who was going to
bring forward who've been paid off by
Trump and then any of those things
evidence to support such an accusation
would surely upend Cavanaugh's
confirmation which has already become a
true noble like political disaster for
the White House according to Vanity Fair
in reality it is not in fact a true
noble like political disaster for the
White House the polls don't show any
impact on Trump on the 2018 election
nothing
hey but Michael avenatti today he
finally comes out with the accusation so
first he was accused of getting this
story from 4chan so the 4chan pranksters
decided that they were going to accuse
avenatti of picking up on some rumor
that they had put out there essentially
for fun in order to harm in order to
harm a vanity avenatti tonight all that
and he came forward and he said that his
client was gonna come forward within 48
hours this clip 11 well rachel i'm
representing one client who i can
describe as a witness and victim as well
as additional corroborating witnesses to
what she is going to allege publicly
within the next 48 hours as it relates
to her particular allegations we're not
going to provide additional information
beyond that so avenatti was acting kind
of suspicious in the run-up to the
release of this for example he began
protecting his tweets which is unusual
for a guy who has said that he wants to
run for president in 2020 he also then
released the the sworn declaration of a
woman named Julie sweat Nick and he
tweeted out a picture of her and said
here's her name here's her picture
please respect her privacy which is a
very weird way to ask for somebody's
privacy in any case here is her
declaration and just came out this
morning quote my name is Julie sweat
Nick and I'm a resident of Washington DC
I fully
understand the seriousness of the
statements contained within this
declaration I have personal knowledge of
the information stated herein and have
called to testify to the same would and
could do so and then she names off all
of the places that she has worked before
she says that she has worked for places
including the Department of the Treasury
and the Internal Revenue Service and the
US Mint she held in she held inactive
security clearances with the Department
of State and the DOJ she says I first
met mark judge and Brett Kavanaugh in
approximately 1980 to 1981 I was
introduced to them at a house party that
I attended in the Washington DC area
I observed mark judge and Brett
Kavanaugh as extremely close friends
during the early 1980s when I knew them
and interacted with them I would
describe them as quote joined-at-the-hip
and I consistently saw them together in
many social settings there is no
question in my mind that mark judge has
significant information concerning the
conduct of Brett Kavanaugh during the
1980s especially as it relates to his
actions towards women following that
first introduction I attended well over
ten house parties in the Washington DC
area during the years 1981 to 1983 or
Marc judge and Brett Kavanaugh are
present these parties were a common
occurrence in the area and occurred
nearly every weekend during the school
year on numerous occasions at these
parties have witnessed mark judge and
Brett Kavanaugh drink excessively and
engage in highly inappropriate conduct
including being overly aggressive with
girls and not taking no for an answer
which is kind of vague because you don't
know what that means then she continues
this conduct included the fondling and
grabbing of girls without their consent
now remember she's not claiming she's
one of these girls she is saying that
she witnessed this sort of behavior says
I observed Brett Kavanaugh drink
excessively at many of these parties and
engage in abusive and physically
aggressive behavior toward girls
including pressing girls against him
without their consent grinding against
girls and attempting to remove or shift
girls clothing to expose private body
parts i likewise observed him to be
verbally abusive toward girls by making
crude sexual comments to them that were
designed to demean humiliate and
embarrass them but so the last part
there is him being a jackass in high
school I often witness Brett Kavanaugh
speak in a demeaning manner about girls
in general as well as specific girls by
name again jackass in high school I also
witness Brett Kavanaugh behave as a mean
drunk on many occasions at these parties
again jackass in high school so far the
only allegation she's made that is
actually damaging is the allegation that
he was engaged in physically aggressive
behavior toward girls without their
consent guys saying mean stuff
girls when they're in high school is
kind of called high school I've been
told by other women that this conduct to
also occur during the summer months in
Ocean City Maryland on numerous
occasions I also witness such conduct on
one occasion in Ocean City Maryland
during Beach week she says I have
reviewed Brett Cavanaugh's recent claim
on Fox News regarding his alleged
innocence during his high school years
and lack of sexual activity we'll get to
that in just a second this claim is
absolutely false and a lie
eyewitness Brett Kavanaugh consistently
engaged in excessive drinking and
inappropriate conduct of a sexual nature
with women during the early 1980s and
then here's where she gets to the actual
damaging allegation and it's a little
vague when as I'll explain in just
second now
there's nothing to suggest that it's non
credible again we have to say whether
it's credible or not she seems like a
credible person from the text of the
actual claim she doesn't seem to be a
complete crazy person although we
haven't seen her speak out loud yet so
we really don't know and it is also
worthwhile noting that she has not been
called to testify in any setting
she is not testifying under oath as far
as I'm aware and Michael avenatti when
specifically asked whether she was
accusing Brett Kavanaugh of indeed being
involved in a gang rape she he he demure
he's not answering the question here is
the actual accusation during the years
1981 1982 I became aware of efforts by
mark judge Brett Kavanaugh and others to
spiked the punch at house parties I
attended with drugs and/or grain alcohol
so as to cause girls to lose their
inhibitions and their ability to say no
this caused me to make an effort to
purposely avoid the punch at these
parties I witnessed efforts by Mark
George Brett Kavanaugh and others to
target particular girls so they could be
taken advantage of it was usually a girl
that was especially vulnerable because
she was alone at the party or shy I also
witnessed efforts by Mark judge Brad
Kavanaugh and others to cause girls to
become inebriated or disoriented so they
could then be gang-raped this is an
actual accusation and a side room or
bedroom by a train of numerous boys I
have a firm recollection of seeing boys
lined up outside rooms at many of these
parties waiting for their turn with a
girl inside the room these boys included
mark judge and Brett Kavanaugh so now
she's saying that she knows that there
was a gang rape train going on and the
line included mark judge and Brett
Kavanaugh that's a natural accusation in
approximately 1982 I became the victim
of one of these gang or train rapes or
mark judge whom Brett Kavanaugh are
present now here's where it gets vague
it's not clear whether she is saying
that they were involved in the gang rape
or train or whether they were just the
party like she was also at the party so
you know there were people at the party
apparently shortly after the incident I
shared what hadn't transpired with at
least two other people during the
incident I was incapacitated without my
consent and unable to fight off the boys
raping me I believe I was drugged using
quaaludes or something similar placed in
what I was drinking so obviously a
pretty terrible story I'm aware of other
witnesses that can attest to the
truthfulness of each of the statements
above and then she swore this under
penalty of perjury
she's executed this declaration as of
yesterday so the question here is a
pretty simple one is it true or is it
false is it true or is it false she's
claiming now that they were at parties
where there were dozens of witnesses
where people saw this gang rape Train
occurring on a regular basis that she
would continue going to these parties on
a regular basis even knowing that these
boys were performing a gang rape train
in the other room which is sort of an
odd sort of suggestion if you went to a
party and you saw people performing gang
rapes there would you can very at least
would you continue going to those
parties on the weekend seems kind of
suspicious the fact that she went to
Michael avenatti to reveal this
particular scenario is also suspicious
bottom line is we're gonna need more
evidence on this we're gonna need some
corroborating details we're gonna need
to know what the weekends were we're
gonna need to know who else was there
she says that she's aware of other
witnesses that can attest to the
truthfulness of each of the statements
above who are these other witnesses we
just don't know at this point we have no
idea so all of this is brand-new we
don't have any of the details as of yet
it's not it's not clear now one of the
things that's happening here is that
Democrats and folks on the Left are
jumping on Brett Cavanaugh's interview
on Fox News last night to claim that
Brett Kavanaugh actually was claiming
that he is clean as the driven snow pure
as the driven snow and therefore if they
can find evidence that he went to
parties and was drinking then he is
therefore a liar and I ought not sit on
the Supreme Court it's his big straw man
that's being set up against Brett
Kavanaugh so here's what Brett Kavanaugh
actually said he's on martha maccallum
show and he talked about his he talked
about his experiences in high school and
here's what he had to say we're talking
about an allegation of sexual assault
I've never sexually assaulted anyone I
did not have sexual intercourse or
anything close to sexual intercourse in
high school or for many years there
after and the girls from the schools I
went to and I were saying that all
through all these years that are in
question you are a virgin that's correct
never had sexual intercourse with anyone
in high school Carothers through what
years in college since we're probing
into your personal years many years
after I'll leave it at that many years
after okay so number one it's kind of
absurd that he's now on TV having to
brag about whether he was a virgin in
high school now somebody who thinks that
there's nothing wrong with being a
virgin in high school or all the way
until marriage I don't have much of a
problem with folks saying this but this
is what our political discourse has now
come to based on unverified allegations
we're gonna get to the unverified nature
of Christian Blasi Ford's allegations in
just a second but to finish up with with
the the Cavanaugh interview here it's
being portrayed by the media as though
Brett Kavanaugh said that he was again
as clean and as pure as anyone has ever
been in high school that's not exactly
what he said and I'll explain in just
one second but first let's talk about
the quality of your sleep we're not
gonna agree on everything but I think we
can all agree we can use more sleep and
you think about a lot of things when you
go to sleep you think about the quality
of the light in your room you think
about the quality of the mattress in
your room but do you think about the
quality of the sheets that you use well
you should because it does make a huge
difference with regards to the kind of
sleep that you get that's why you ought
to be using bull and branch everything
bull and branch makes from bedding to
blankets is made from pure 100% organic
cotton which means they start out super
soft and they get even softer over time
you can buy directly from them so that
you are actually paying direct prices as
opposed to paying the middleman luxury
sheets can cost up to a thousand dollars
in places like bull and in places like
Bed branch Bed Bath and Beyond but go to
a bull and branch website and their
sheets are gonna cost you only a couple
of hundred bucks everybody who tries
Bull and bran sheets love them which is
why they have thousands of five-star
reviews
I like their sheets so much that after
my wife and I tried them out not only
did we buy a few more sets we actually
got rid of all the other sheets in our
house because they are indeed that
comfortable three u.s. presidents sleep
on bull and branch sheets shipping is
free you can try them for 30 nights if
you don't love them send them back for a
refund but you're not gonna want to send
them back but it's risk free so why not
try it out to get you started right now
my listeners can get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at bull and branch
comm promo code Ben go to bull and
branch comm today again for $50 off your
first set of sheets that's bol and
komm promo code Ben Bowlin branch comm
promo code Ben go check it out so here
is what Brett Kavanaugh actually said
about his life during high school he
says yes there were parties and the
drinking age was 18 and yes the seniors
were legal and had beer there and yes
people might have had too many beers on
occasion and people generally in high
school I think all of us have probably
done things we look back on in high
school and regret or cringe a bit but
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about an allegation of
sexual assault
I've never sexually assaulted anyone
right that's that's when he gets to the
part that he was talking about so
McCallum asked him sir you're gonna be
pressed on something he just said about
people do things in high school and you
were all drinking were there times
perhaps when you drank so much was there
ever a time you drank so much you
couldn't remember what happened the
night before and Cavanaugh said no that
never happened McCallum said he never
said to anyone I don't remember about
anything about last night and Cavanaugh
said no that never happened so the great
lie here that is being promulgated is
that Brett Kavanaugh is is saying that
he was completely innocent in high
school that he never drank to excess
that he was never involved in raucous
parties or anything like that but that
wasn't the accusation remember the
original accusation is that he tried to
rape a girl and the original accusation
is that he pushed a fifteen-year-old
girl into a room pulled down her clothes
and tried to rape her and then stifled
her screams with his hand as she tried
to cry out now we have the second
accusation from from avenatti and it's
not even clear at this point what
exactly the accusation is because the
woman who's making the claim is
basically saying that she's present at
parties where gang rapes were occurring
and she saw Brent Cavanaugh in line and
she saw Brett Kavanaugh I guess grabbed
and fondled girls but those girls
haven't come forward and then she's
making a claim that she was gang-raped
in one of these parties but and Brett
Kavanaugh was present at the party but
not clear that Brent Cavanaugh is
actually involved in the gang rape so
the extent of the claims that she's
making is not particularly clear and you
can see that the media are attempting to
push the boundaries of the actual
accusation now the media are moving into
the arena of suggesting that Brett
Kavanaugh was basically a sloppy drunk
that's the active the new accusation
against him is that he was a sloppy
drunk so they're gonna claim that he's a
sexual assault her and if they can't
prove that they're gonna claim that he
was a sloppy drunk and therefore if he
was a sloppy drunk and he lied about it
he shouldn't sit on the Supreme Court so
we're seeing a sort of mission creep
with regard to
what Democrats are claiming about him
depending on how seriously they end up
taking Michael a vanadis suggestions
okay so speaking of that the Washington
Post has a long piece today about
Cavanaugh's so quote-unquote choirboy
image now again I'm not sure what makes
people think that Brett Cavanaugh has
claimed for himself a choirboy image as
I just read to you from the transcript
of McCallum show he is not claiming that
he had a choirboy image right he is
saying that he was drinking to excess at
parties but the Washington Post has a
long piece today an investigative piece
about Brett Kavanaugh drank a lot okay
drinking a lot in high school if that
were a crime ninety percent of the
American public would be ineligible for
any government job really I mean the
amounts of drinking that goes on in high
schools across America is exorbitant its
exorbitant but the Washington Post has
this long piece today they say on Monday
night Supreme Court nominee Brett
Kavanaugh said in a nationally televised
interview and in his younger years he
was focused on sports academics and
service projects but it was his comments
about drinking that rankled some Yale
University classmates prompting them to
speak out for the first time liz Swisher
who described herself as a friend of
Cavanaugh in college said she was
shocked that in an interview focused
largely on his high school years and
allegations of sexual misconduct he
strongly tonight drinking to the point
of blacking out Brett was a sloppy drunk
and I know because I drank with him I
watched him drink more than a lot of
people he'd end up slurring his words
and stumbling said Swisher a Democrat
and chief of the gynecological oncology
division at the University of Washington
School of Medicine there's no medical
way I can say that he was blacked out
but it's not credible for him to say he
has had no memory lapses in the nights
that he drank to excess well but I don't
understand what that means like he said
that he wasn't a blackout drunk and then
he says that he remembered what went on
that's completely subjective I'm not
sure exactly how you would claim that he
had memory lapses when he didn't have
when he claims you know memory lapses
Lynne Brooks who like Swisher was a
college roommate of one of the two women
now accusing Cavanaugh of misconduct
said the nominees comments on Fox did
not match the classmate she remembered
he's trying to paint himself as some
sort of choirboy said Brooks a
Republican and former pharmaceutical
executive who were called an encounter
with a drunken Kavanagh at a frat event
he can't lie your way onto the Supreme
Court and with that statement out he's
gone too far it's about the integrity of
that institution so now the accusation
made by the Washington Post and made by
these women is that if Brett Kavanaugh
looked too clean in that interview then
he shouldn't be on the Supreme Court so
it's no longer sexual
it's Brett Kavanaugh looked like a
choirboy in that interview and he wasn't
a choirboy back when he was in high
school and college but as I say in an
interview he said that he went to
parties where too much drinking occurred
and he says he got drunk so I don't know
what exactly the accusation is so now
they are trying to basically say that he
perjured himself on the basis of all of
this
they perjured himself on the basis of
did you get drunk in high school that's
not gonna cut it
it's just not going to cut it and then
meanwhile there's another allegation
that they've brought forth the Democrats
have brought forth and it is indeed an
extraordinarily weak allegation okay
it's an allegation from The New Yorker
this Brooke Sunday afternoon there's a
known allegation from Ronan Farrow and
Jane Mayer over at The New Yorker and
this allegation is basically a nothing
okay the claim dates to the 1983 1984
academic school year when Kavanagh was a
freshman at Yale University according to
The New Yorker the offices of at least
four Democratic senators have received
information about the allegation at
least two began investigating it senior
Republican staffers learned about the
allegations last week the woman at the
center of the stories woman named
Deborah Ramirez she has consistently
refused to testify under oath she's not
testifying under oath she's made clear
that she's not testifying under oath in
fact her own attorney said that she
would probably not be testifying under
oath right she said she her own her own
attorney said that she wasn't convinced
of the veracity of her own memories with
regard to this particular accusation
this is clip 7 here's her attorney
explaining that she didn't even know
whether her own acted her own memory the
situation was true and yet we're
supposed to take it seriously with that
passage of time you know she went
through those memories and there were
some things that she believed were
probably true but she didn't disclose
those because she wasn't completely
convinced of their accuracy so that's
the only reason why she did the work
with the attorney and spent the six days
to make sure that that information she
did put forward was indeed accurate so
in other words she didn't remember and
then she talked to her attorneys for six
days and democratic staffers for six
days and then she came forward a lot of
problems with this particular story even
Ronan Farrow seems uncomfortable that he
ran this story in the first place the
woman at the center of that story's
woman in Deborah Ramirez she's 53 she
attended Yale with Cavanaugh she studied
sociology and psychology The New Yorker
contacted Ramirez after learning of her
possible
involvement in an incident involving
Kavanagh how did they hear about that
well they heard about it from Democrats
and the Democrats referred this woman to
the New York or The New Yorker ran with
the story f vid says quote after six
days of carefully assessing her memories
and consulting with her attorney Ramirez
says she felt confident enough of her
recollections to say that she remembers
Kavanagh had exposed himself at a
drunken dorm party thrust his genitals
in her face and caused her to touch it
without her consent as she pushed it
away and then she says she wants an FBI
investigation but won't testify under
oath and Cavanaugh of course completely
denies the allegation and a bunch of
witnesses say that they don't know what
exactly what exactly she is talking
about so this allegation is again really
weak as well the allegations that been
put forth are unverified this latest
allegation from avenatti we're gonna
have to see whether anybody comes
forward to verify it but right now all
of this looks just like I mean it looks
it looks weak I gotta be honest with you
it looks weak I don't trust avenatti
this woman coming forward it's not
brought any other witnesses of
corroborating detail so we're gonna have
to find out about that and the fact that
all of this is being conjured out of
thin air by Democrats makes me a little
suspicious of all this speaking of which
we're going to show you in one second
all of the reactions of the political
players to all of this we're gonna get
to that and we're gonna get to the big
hearing that's supposed to happen
tomorrow on Capitol Hill if Christine
Blasi floor decides to show up but first
let's talk about your investment
strategy Robin Hood is an investing app
that lets you buy and sell stocks ETFs
options and cryptos all commission-free
they strive to make Financial Services
work for everyone not just for wealthy
folks it's simple and intuitive it's a
clear design with clear data presented
in an easy to digest way folks in our
office have tried the Robin Hood app
they say that it really looks good I
mean I've looked at it as well and it is
a very clean looking app it does make
trading extraordinarily easy and
provides you information at the click of
a button touch of a finger the their
costs fee their their structure fee is
pretty great other brokerages charge up
to 10 bucks for every trade but Robin
Hood doesn't charge Commission fees you
can trade the stocks and keep all of
your profits they've all these easy to
understand charts market data you can
even group by 100 most popular sectors
like entertainment or social media and
this teaches you to invest simply by
doing because just put a little money in
there and you can play around with it
and see how you like to invest Robin
Hood is giving my
there's a free stock like Apple
four-door sprint right now to help you
build your portfolio all you have to do
is go to Shapiro Robinhood calm
that's Shapiro dot Robinhood calm go
check it out right now Shapiro dot Robin
Hood calm again Shapiro dot Robin Hood
calm great app go check it out right now
and save money because you're not using
any of those other apps go check it out
Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm okay so the
political reaction to all of this
continues to play out there's a big
story yesterday that seems a little bit
overblown this is that the Senate
Judiciary Committee will vote on Bret
Cavanaugh's nomination to the Supreme
Court on Friday morning less than 24
hours after Cavanaugh and Christine
Blasi Ford this is the original accuser
appear before the panel to discuss
Ford's allegation the Cavanaugh sexually
assaulted her more than thirty years ago
speaking of which there was an there's
an amazing media report out today from
Peter Alexander who's over at NBC News
and Peter Alexander puts out he says NBC
News has obtained sworn and signed
declarations from for people who
corroborate Christine Blasi Ford's
claims of sexual assault against
Cavanaugh sense of the Senate committee
will that be pretty damning stuff right
I mean for people corroborating her
claims except none of the four none of
the four declarations actually
corroborate her claims all of the alley
all of the declarations basically say
that Christine blaze he Ford told them
about it thirty years later that is not
corroboration if I claim right now on
this show that Diane Feinstein
slaughters puppies in her backyard and
then I get signed declarations from the
million people who listen to this show
saying that they heard me claim that
Dianne Feinstein slaughters puppies in
her backyard that is not actually a
corroboration of the claim that dianne
feinstein slaughters puppies in her
backyard you're corroborating the claim
that i said it
you're not corroborating that it
happened but the media say that this
claim has now been corroborate and this
is the problem with all of these stories
these all should be easily verified and
corroborated as these happen in public
settings these happened at parties to
date there are zero witnesses outside of
the accusers themselves who have backed
up any aspect of any of these stories
deborah Ramirez's story in The New
Yorker no one at any of the parties
backs up her story apparently this
happened in public this did not happen
in private Christine Blasi Fortas
stories there is nothing there there is
nothing there that
actually has backed up her story
including the witnesses that she herself
is named all of them have denied that
anything like this happened they say
they haven't seen anything like this
this new avenatti accuser says that
there are other witnesses okay so where
are the other witnesses anytime now just
bring them bring them on up bring them
on up I mean this is this is amazing by
the way it is worth noting that if these
accusations that are now being brought
forth by avenatti are true Kavanaugh
shouldn't just lose his Supreme Court
seat he should lose his DC Circuit Court
see Ram if he was involved in gang rapes
with quaaludes when he was in his teens
seems to me that that's who shouldn't be
sitting on any Court let alone the let
alone the Supreme Court of the United
States but we're gonna need some
verifying evidence supposedly everybody
knew about all of this supposedly this
was all this was all clear so that I
mean that this is what's what's it's
it's just hard to honestly it's hard to
buy the avenatti story it's hard to buy
the avenatti story because she's saying
there tons of witnesses to gang rape and
nobody has come forward yet
i means guy's an absolute sociopathic
monster if this is true forget choirboy
the guy's Hitler if this is true I mean
these accusations are as bad as they get
but in the end for Democrats it's really
not about presumption of innocence Chuck
Schumer said as much here's the Senate
Minority Leader saying that Brett
Kavanaugh and his hearing on Thursday is
not entitled to a presumption of
innocence or guilt
they're just fact-finding so we
shouldn't suggest that he's innocent
until proven guilty or innocence until
preponderance of the evidence shows
otherwise or anything the burden of
proof according to according to Chuck
Schumer doesn't exist there is no burden
of proof yes the quote presumption of
innocence I agree that we this is not
that's a criminal trial what what I
believe is we ought to get to the bottom
and find the facts in the way that the
FBI has always done there's no
presumption of innocence or guilt when
you have a nominee before you okay no
presumption of innocence or guilt well I
mean the American public should have
some presumption of innocence otherwise
what are we supposed to do just believe
every accuser that comes along without
any other evidence I mean really I guess
that's the suggestion here he says
there's no presumption of innocence or
guilt but there's an a presumption of
something right because that presumption
decides the burden of proof so in court
when you say somebody's innocent until
proven guilty
that means the quote/unquote burden of
proof is on the prosecutors
that the person is guilty the burden is
not on the on the person being accused
to show that they are innocent the
burden lies with one party or the other
party it doesn't lie in between there's
no way to have a situation where there's
no presumption of guilt or innocence
that doesn't exist right either you
presume that the accusation is true in
which you presume he's guilty or you
presume that the accusation is not true
until proven otherwise in which case you
presume that he's innocent but the idea
that there's no presumption either way
and we are just a fact-finding inquiry
like you're the police kind of hard to
credit when Democrats have trotted this
out every step of the way is politically
as humanly possible it's really this all
frankly it stinks I'm a part of the
Democrats it just stinks it just stinks
I mean it's it's very difficult to
credit any of this by the way Brett
Kavanaugh has denied a vanadis
accusations already he did it
preemptively in his interview with
Martha McCallum he says listen all these
accusations that I was involved in a
gang rape just nonsense he he he said
this on Fox did you ever participate in
or were you ever aware of any gang rape
that happened at a party that you
attended that's totally false and
outrageous never done any such thing
known about any such thing when I was in
high school and I went to an all-boys
Catholic High School a Jesuit High
School where I was focused on academics
and athletics going to church every
Sunday at Little Flower working on my
service projects and friendship
friendship with my fellow classmates and
friendship with girls from the local
all-girls Catholic schools okay so he's
denied the accusations that avenatti is
putting forward already and that's
perfectly obvious that he's denying the
accusations that have been put forward
but Democrats again they are they're
playing a game here where we don't even
know where the burden of proof lies
we're not we just don't know right we
have no clue where where they're even
putting the burden of proof what their
specific allegation is what they have to
prove in order for them to knock
Kavanagh out of the box none of this is
clear and so President Trump when he
comes forward he says listen this seems
to me like a con game I got to agree
with the President of the United States
here's President Trump speaking on this
normally I hate when he speaks about
stuff like this but when he's right he's
right and I think what he says here is
basically correct this is a con game
being played by the Democrats also
take a look at the lawyers these lawyers
are the same lawyers that have been
fighting for years they keep fighting
take a look at the lawyers okay again I
don't think that there's anything wrong
with him saying that and I think that
he's basically right that this has all
been gins up by Democrats at this point
I mean look at look at Kirsten
Gillibrand who basically said the Brett
Cavanaugh should be calling for an FBI
investigation into himself or he's
guilty in some way which is essentially
a Stalinist tactic now she's saying Fox
News is evil because they're trying to
confuse people about Kavanaugh no
they're trying to say you're gonna need
to show some proof of something here but
here she is making the claim anyway
every time you hear on Fox News Oh
innocent you know assume you're innocent
you can have to have prove beyond a
reasonable doubt they're trying to
confuse voters they're trying to confuse
people across this country
that's what Mathis is this isn't that is
not what this is about no you are trying
to confuse people across this country by
not making clear your standard of proof
am I not making clear the nature of an
accusation you think should rule
somebody out of politics again if the
accusation is he got drunk in high
school guilty he says he got drunk in
high school if the accusation is that he
sexually assaulted somebody I don't know
what you're gonna be able to do with
that
like I just I don't understand what
exactly the accusation is you know the
it's it's very difficult it's very
difficult to figure out exactly what
what the claim is like really I'm having
a difficult time coming up with with
what the claim is because Christine
Blasi Ford has made a claim it is not
clear to me what exactly what exactly
the evidence is for that claim is it
enough to claim that he grabs a girl and
pushed her on a bed and made her and she
screamed he put her hand over her mouth
yes obviously I'd be enough to rule him
out would it be enough to claim he was
part of a gang rape train yes is it
enough to claim he was drunk in high
school no that would clearly not be
enough and yet Democrats keep trying to
expand the borders of this particular
claim now in a second we're gonna get
into all of the details of this hearing
that's supposed to take place tomorrow
but first let's talk about life
insurance so September is national life
insurance Awareness Month if you listen
to this show a lot you've heard me talk
about how important life insurance is
but here is the thing 40% of Americans
still don't have life insurance which is
foolish because if you plot your family
is basically screwed so make sure that
you go out and get life insurance today
and the best way to do that is by going
over to policy genius com policy genius
is the easy way to get life insurance
online
in two minutes you can compare quotes
from the top insurers and find the best
policy for you and when you compare
quotes you save money it's that simple
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance they've placed
over 20 billion dollars in coverage and
they don't just make life insurance easy
they also do disability insurance and
renter's insurance and health insurance
if you care about it they can cover it
so if you're looking for a good reason
to buy life insurance I've got three
it's national life insurance awareness
month rates are at a 20-year low and
policy genius makes it easy for you to
get the right policy for you there
really is no reason not to have a life
insurance policy this is just basic
responsible adult thing go to policy
genius com get those quotes apply in
minutes you can do the whole thing on
your phone right now
policy genius is indeed the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance go over
to policy genius comm and get those
quotes and apply in minutes alrighty so
we're gonna discuss what we can expect
at the hearing tomorrow plus president
Trump at the UN and Ted Cruz being
chased out of a restaurant we'll get to
all that stuff but you're gonna have to
go over to Daley wire calm and subscribe
for $9.99 a month you can get the rest
of Daley wires shows right and get them
all live you get the rest of my show
live you get the rest of Andrew clavin's
show liveing at the rest of michael
Molesey show live plus when you
subscribe you also automatically
download and have access to our Sundays
specials which are just fabulous we have
an extra question that we asked on the
Sunday special you can't get unless you
are a subscriber this week Sundays
special features Cameron caskey parkland
student who is present during the during
the mass shooting and was a member of
March for lives he's now left March for
our lives a really interesting interview
I think that you'll enjoy it
hey everyone I'm Cameron Caskey these
are my tears and I'm on the Sunday
special so go check that out right now I
think Cameron is really genuine kid I
think that I'm old enough to call him
the kid which freaks me out but I think
Jake Cameron is a genuine guy trying to
search for some better answers for
himself and at least have honest
conversation so you're gonna want to
hear this one
I think that it's worthwhile also go
check us out at YouTube or iTunes
subscribe to this review we always
appreciate it I don't have my left is
tears hydrocal tumblr so I hold up my
invisible one that I bring with me
whenever I am on the road this one right
here is a $99 subscription tumbler it is
magnificent it is better than the $9.99
a month subscription because hey it's
cheaper and also you get a mug with the
the powers of invisibility which is
pretty incredible so go check that out
right now we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so here is the latest on the hearing
that's supposed to take place on
Thursday Democrats keep trying to push
off these hearings keep trying to
prevent anybody from actually testifying
two days ago senator Feinstein the
ranking Democrat on the Senate Judiciary
Committee according to The Washington
Post called for a delay in further
consideration of Brett Kavanaugh after a
second woman accused him of sexual
misconduct
she said I'm writing to request an
immediate postponement of any further
proceedings related to the nomination of
Brett Kavanaugh does it seem like a
group of people who desperately want to
have their clients testify does this
seem like a group of people who really
want to have their clients questioned by
prosecutors seems to me like not and
Democrats are very upset because
Republicans are going to have an Arizona
prosecutor asking the questions instead
of members of the committee
according to LMT online Republican
senators have selected Arizona
prosecutor Rachel Mitchell to question
judge Brett Kavanaugh and the woman who
has accused the Supreme Court nominee of
sexually assaulting her when they were
teenagers according to a top senator
Mitchell is the sex crimes bureau chief
for the Maricopa County Attorney's
Office in Phoenix and she's going to
query the two at Thursday's highly
anticipated Senate Judiciary Committee
hearing she's a registered Republican
she's worked for the Maricopa County
Attorney's Office for 26 years because
she's in Maricopa County this has led
Democrats to claim that they basically
went through Sheriff Joe Arpaio to come
up with this prosecutor there's no
evidence of that whatsoever she's a well
respected prosecutor in this particular
region Republicans are turning to her to
ask all the questions specifically
because she's a woman let's be honest
about this they're doing this because
Democrats claimed that Republican
senators should not ask questions
because they were men so Republicans
said okay well how about we bring a
woman and Democrats said that's not fair
because we wanted it to be men so you'd
look bad I'm not kidding this is exactly
what Democrats are saying amazing Hirono
who's the Democrat from Democrat senator
from Hawaii she basically said that
right after spending days and days and
days saying it's just terrible that all
these old white men want to question
this young woman who has a traumatic
experience in her past now when
Republicans say okay we'll have a woman
do it now the Democrats come forth they
say it's just terrible these old white
men won't question this young
traumatized woman here's mazie Hirono
doing just that but it should be very
obvious to the people of our country by
now that the Republicans do not
to question dr. Ford directly because
they will reveal who they are and I
think they're afraid of that
okay so they they don't want the
Republicans questioning them but they
also don't want a woman questioning them
which suggests again this does not look
like these do not look like honest
allegations that are coming from an
honest place for the Democrats now maybe
all of this happen and if it all
happened as I say over and over and over
these are egregious crimes that he's
being accused of if they are true he
should lose his job right I mean he
should he should not sit on the DC
Circuit Court of Appeals let alone the
Supreme Court but it seems to me much
more like Democrats just want to create
a miasma of confusion around Kavanagh
based on unverified allegations
Hirono is making that obvious right
Hirono says that Kavanagh will always
have an asterisk covers name no matter
what happens from now on which is a
pretty hellish standard if the way we're
going to now run things is that there's
an asterisk by our name if an allegation
is even made about you what's to prevent
allegations from being made about
everyone at anytime for any reason and
then there's just a cloud surrounding
you that's why we require evidence
that's why evidence is useful if we're
gonna ruin somebody's life at the very
least we got to have some evidence there
life ought to be ruined that's not what
we've seen so far here's Hirono should
he get on the court there will always be
an asterisk and a cloud over his name
and on his name and I think that is not
what we want to to do to the Supreme
Court and to be frank about this you
know when she says that there always
been asterisk over his name Democrats
have tried to place an asterisk by the
name of every single justice who's been
appointed by a Republican for the last
25 years Clarence Thomas george w bush
appointed two of them democrats say he
wasn't even elected properly so both of
those should be out of bounds and now
they're trying to do the exact same
thing with both with both with both
Gorsuch and now with Kavanagh right both
of them were appointed by Trump who lost
the popular vote and who stole the seat
from Merrick garland so all five of the
justices appointed by Republicans who
currently are sitting on the quarter
about to sit on the court
Democrats have attempted to create a
miasma of confusion about and that
miasma of confusion extends to the way
that they talk about the case itself so
Christine Blasi Ford is the one who
wants to limit the Senate coverage and
she says she only wants one camera in
the room and apparently Republicans
agreed to that which is insane
that's insane I don't even know why you
would agree to such a thing why would
you agree to one camera in the room
and we have one camera in the room right
now why because there's only one target
for the camera in the room it's me but
if we wanted kolten on camera now were
asking quilting questions you need two
cameras in the room otherwise you just
got the camera swiveling okay that's
silly
you don't want to see my reaction to
Colton's answers for example if ever we
were to interview kolten for some
bizarre reason okay but the reality is
that in this particular case you need a
camera on her you need a camera on the
person asking the questions you need two
cameras Republicans apparently agreed to
one she doesn't want mass press coverage
so she wants to limit the number of
people in the room I don't understand
how she's being allayed allowed to get
away with any of this she was allowed to
drive across the country instead of fly
based on what not clear right none of
that is clear all of this just it just
stinks to high heaven it just stinks to
high heaven until I see more evidence I
cannot buy into this is not to say that
the allegations if they are credible and
if they are if there's any evidence to
them that they shouldn't be damaging
they should but because they are
damaging that's why we need evidence
that's the whole purpose of having
evidence in any of these cases in the
first place okay so meanwhile Ted Cruz
was chased out of a restaurant and he
you want to generate sympathy for Ted
Cruz all you have to do is unleash a
bunch of a bunch of nasty leftists on
him so he went to a restaurant in the
Washington DC area apparently and he was
immediately chased out of the restaurant
by a bunch of lefties who were screaming
at him
okay so you need there with his wife and
they're not letting his wife through and
they're trying to impede her path just
really classy folks these are these
folks are just classy this is smash
racism DC because obviously this has to
do with racism for some odd reason that
nobody knows so they're a bunch of
videos around this apparently one shows
a woman who identified herself as a
constituent and a survivor of sexual
assault said I'd love to talk with you
about Brett Kavanaugh I'm a constituent
love to know what your vote is going to
be I know you're very close friends the
mr. Cavanaugh do you believe survivors
sir again this is such a stupid
questions you believe survivors
I believe survivors when there's
evidence to back their case I'm not
saying I don't believe survivors when
there's not evidence but I don't have
enough evidence to say I fully believe
that I can say I find their account
credible but I can't say I fully believe
every detail of that account without any
corroborate of evidence from 30 years
ago I can't do that
okay because what meant that it's a it's
a leading question it's a circular
question do you believe survivors
assumes the truth of the accusation
right I mean that because you're saying
she's a survivor so that means that that
the accusation is by necessity true and
saying like do you believe the accounts
of a Holocaust survivor yes because
you'd call them a Holocaust survivor hey
do I believe the account of Richard
Blumenthal that he served in Vietnam no
right because he wasn't telling the
truth about all of that so it depends on
the account that's being that's being
stated do you believe survivors is not a
proper it's not a properly formed
question as we might say in the legal
profession it is an improperly formed
question the question is do you believe
every allegation of sexual assault every
ever made by a woman that is the
question that actually is is to be asked
and the answer to that obviously should
be no because there are some accusations
that are not true or people must
remember or they get the facts wrong but
that means that we have to run Ted Cruz
out of a restaurant and people on the
Left will say well you know that's good
Ted Cruz deserves it you got to live out
your values in public life
listen I'm lucky I go to kosher
restaurants and I'm pretty popular with
my crew so when I go to kosher
restaurants this has never happened to
me but I could see it happening if I was
ever out to lunch with some folks you
know and just having my typical water
while they eat a nice dinner you know if
I Rivera if I were to do that I could
see this happening the idea that we were
going to extend all of this to public
life you want a worse country where
we're getting there right here so beta
O'Rourke condemned it good for
he said not right that senator Cruz and
his wife Heidi were surrounded and
forced to leave a restaurant last night
because of protesters the Cruz family
should be treated with respect
O'Rourke is exactly correct of course
and we know that in June Maxine Waters
suggested that people do exactly the
sort of thing so this is a split among
members of the Democratic Party as to
whether this sort of activity is okay or
not okay meanwhile President Trump was
at the UN yesterday he's at the UN today
as well he's presiding over the Security
Council and it is in fact deeply amusing
to watch him gavel to silence the
constituencies of the representatives of
China for example he's actually sitting
there with a gavel which is pretty
awesome but he gave a speech at the UN
General Assembly yesterday and it was
quite good there was a lot there that
was quite good he said that we defend
sovereignty this was his sort of main
claim I think that this particular claim
is not one of his best and he says we
defend sovereignty of other nations and
then he sort of suggests that they get
to define their own values that's true
to a point obviously it is not true to
the ultimate point which is that you get
to define how you treat your people
without any sort of interference from
the outside that obviously is untrue but
here was the president making his main
point talking about America first in
sovereignty to unleash this incredible
potential in our people we must defend
the foundations that make it all
possible sovereign and independent
nations are the only vehicle where
freedom has ever survived democracy has
ever endured where peace has ever
prospered and so we must protect our
sovereignty and our cherished
independence above all so I agree with
all of that right everything that he
just said there about nationalism
actually being a good vehicle everything
there about nationalism being a good
vehicle for for human society agree and
you have a global government were all
brothers a brotherhood of man as john
lennon's has an imagined that's a bunch
of nonsense with that said even Trump
believes that nationalism doesn't mean
that that sovereignty is completely is
completely left alone right so for
example he said this about socialism and
communism he basically said Venezuela
can't run things like the Venezuelan
government is currently running things
that's a breach of Venezuelan
sovereignty on imagine the basic rule
about Venezuela and the basic rule about
national
the nationalism is good so long as it
follows good follows good ends and uses
good means it is not good so long as it
involves you know genocide against a
population or so long as it involves
socialism and communism and destruction
of the rights of the individual here is
a president Trump going off about
Venezuela he's correct about this
obviously virtually everywhere socialism
or communism has been tried it has
produced suffering corruption and decay
socialism's thirst for power leads to
expansion incursion and oppression all
nations of the world should resist
socialism and the misery that it brings
to everyone in that spirit we ask the
nations gathered here to join us in
calling for the restoration of democracy
in Venezuela okay so obviously when he
talks about sovereignty he only means
that sovereignty applies so far as it
doesn't violate sovereign human rights
and individual rights which is correct
which is correct and I think that he
should make that clear in future
speeches but a lot of this was very good
in it is good to have a president who
goes before the UN and doesn't make
apologies for the United States I mean
when I think President Trump is at his
best in international scenarios because
a muscular America on the world stage
defending her own interests is a very
good thing for the world as a general
rule a America that goes in front of the
UN and apologizes for Ferguson or
Baltimore which is what Barack Obama did
in front of the UN apologizes for
American interests apologizes for
America promoting her own interests
around the world suggesting that
national sovereignty of bad countries is
more important than human rights or
national sovereignty of good countries
now that was devastating stuff and I
know there are a lot of people's oh well
you know President Trump went there he
got laughed at by the international
community why do you care if a
second-rate dictator is laughing at you
so long as we're taking action to stop
the second-rate dictator I would much
prefer that the second-rate radical
Islamic dictators of Iran laugh at
President Trump and feel it in their
pocketbook then they smile at President
Obama and enrich themselves on the back
of their own people and then use all of
that money to fund terrorism so
President Trump I thought did a just
fine job at the UN in the General
Assembly
yesterday the the best I mean the way
that he talked about Israel and Iran I
thought was just terrific
you know here's what the president said
with regard to with regard to Iran it's
very different language than President
Obama was using just a couple of years
ago this year we also took another
significant step forward in the Middle
East in recognition of every sovereign
state to determine its own capital I
move the US Embassy in Israel to
Jerusalem the United States is committed
to a future of peace and stability in
the region including peace between the
Israelis and the Palestinians that aim
is advanced not harmed by acknowledging
the obvious facts okay and then what he
had to say about the Israelis and
Palestinians obviously a far cry for
when Barack Obama would go to the UN and
suggest that all world problems were to
be laid at the feet of the Jews there
would be laid at the feet of the
Israelis who are of course so
intransigent with regards who you know
the terrorist groups on their borders
and if they would only be a little nicer
that would solve the problems with
regard to Iran I do like that the
president's America first attitude on
the world stage means that we're going
to stand up to bad countries again he
was doing that today in the in the
Security Council apparently he said
today in the Security Council that China
has been attempting to interfere with
our elections he suggested that Russian
interference in Syria cannot go
unnoticed now all of that is is very
good stuff so good for the presidents of
the United States more of that more of
the president speaking on international
affairs in the face of countries that
are pursuing evil ends and you know less
of the president tweeting I think the
last several weeks for the president
have actually been quite good he's
really kept himself from saying the the
obviously dumb thing much more
frequently than than usual and then
that'd be good I'd like to see
continuation of that again if I were
running the president's team I would be
sending the president abroad as often as
possible to talk about how bad Iran is
to talk about foreign policy and
building up America's military capacity
to talk about building up America
economically the president performs
pretty well overseas generally generally
I'm not gonna include Helsinki in that
particular assessment okay so let's do a
couple of things I like and then a
couple
things I hate and then we will be back
here tomorrow with a lot more from the
Christine blaze before hearing so things
I like over the Jewish holidays I did
some light reading I was reading
Paradise Lost by John Milton if you've
never actually read Paradise Lost that
is a masterful use of the English
language and people miss read Paradise
Lost so because we live in a post
Romantic era in which people value
emotions above facts and in which people
value rebellion and passion above
I think lucid thought people for a long
time have identified Satan in Paradise
Lost as sort of the antihero that really
the hero of Paradise Lost is Satan right
Satan fights a war with God because he
doesn't feel like paying obeisance to
God all the time and so God cast him
down and then Satan infiltrates the
world that acts as the snake in order to
seduce mankind into original sin and
then God sends Jesus in order to make up
for the original sin basically but but
Satan gets all the good speeches and
there's no question about this and when
you read it Satan gets all the good
dialogue so everything Satan says is
really compelling because good evil
characters on film and in place and in
Paradise Lost are very compelling
because something draws us to the
passion of evil that's true but Milton
specifically said that this book was
written and this epic poem was written
as a piece of theodicy who's trying to
explain why bad things happen to good
people why original sin occurred what
God's actual plan is trying to justify
the actions of God and if you read it
with sympathy for Satan in mind you're
getting it completely wrong the whole
point is that Satan is cunning the whole
point is that Satan is deceptive the
whole point is that Satan is attractive
and then if we are to look to our own
lives and see the activities of what we
in Judaism will call the eighth's our
Hara that kind of evil inclination we
would see that it's not as obvious as
somebody just saying let's go do
something evil it really more often is
somebody saying saying let's go do
something brave let's go do something
spectacular let's go do something that
that fits our ends and if in doing so we
have to break a few eggs well I guess
that will have to do that there's
something attractive about that to the
human nature to the human mind that
doesn't mean that Satan is right and God
is wrong it means that we are wrong then
God is right and that's what Paradise
Lost is really about it's the the word
choice the biblical reference is it's
just magnificent I'd really never spent
any time with it before it's it's truly
incredible so go check it out
Paradise Lost by John Milton ok time for
a couple of things that I hate
so things that I hate today
so bill cosby good was convicted on an
account of date rape basically where he
was quaalude in women and and then
having sex with them against their will
which is what michael avenatti is now
accusing sort of Brett Kavanaugh of
doing so if Brett Kavanaugh is guilty of
it then obviously Brett Kavanaugh should
go down but you're gonna need some
actual proof so Bill Cosby's lawyer said
the dumbest thing that it's possible to
say here and he said that the bill cause
being persecuted here after
acknowledging that he used quaaludes
like Bill Cosby said he himself said he
used quaaludes when he was with women
his lawyer says that this was just like
the persecution of Jesus Jesus didn't
date rape people just FYI for those
who've never had the New Testament
nothing in there about Jesus using that
turning the water into the wine without
the consent of the women that was not
that was not actually a thing so here is
Bill Cosby's lawyer saying silly things
mr. Cosby's doing great and mr. Cosby
knows that God is watching over him he
knows that these are lies they
persecuted Jesus and look what happened
not saying mr. Cosby Jesus but we know
what this country has done to black men
for centuries
well I don't think that this is about
his race I think this has a lot more to
do with the fact that there are a bunch
of women as in dozens of women who came
forward with credible allegations all of
which backed one another now here's the
part where cats die see a CNN guest goes
on and says you can't defend Cavanaugh
and celebrate the cosby verdict really
can't I why not you know well during the
break I'm scrolling through Twitter and
I'm looking at people actually saying
and applauding the judge and in this
sentence and then in the same breath
wanting to defend Cavanaugh and I and
it's disturbing to me because again like
Arriba said this is a monumental
defining moment this week when you have
someone like coffee going to prison and
then in the same breath having Kavanagh
possibly going to the highest court in
the land
and so anyone that stiphu dito Wald her
name is it is idiotic her name is Jodi
to wall she's a criminal defense
attorney and former prosecutor no the
difference is that there was actual
evidence in the Bill Cosby case like her
robert of evidence contemporaneous
accounts admissions against interest by
the person who is being prosecuted not
the same thing the facts that Democrats
are trying to
linked together cause being Kavanagh
without actual evidence they Cavanaugh
did any of this stuff yet outside of the
allegations themselves pretty
astonishing and demonstrative just how
intellectually bankrupt a lot of folks
on the Left are when the evidence is
presented I am more than happy to follow
the evidence but I'm actually gonna have
to see that evidence that doesn't make
me a sexist it doesn't make me someone
who takes sexual abuse lightly
it makes me someone who likes evidence
before we decide that we're going to
destroy somebody based on accusations
alone unsourced accusations alone okay
well we will be back here tomorrow with
all the latest high drama as christine
Blasi florida heads to the Senate to
testify being questioned by an Arizona
prosecutor Brett Kavanaugh will be there
as well and we will be there to cover
all of it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018